hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
candy crush soda level 415 walkthrough
with commentary tips this is a really
tough level and there's not a whole lot
unfortunately that I can tell you except
for the way that we need to try to
approach it is to go after these purple
the eighth color the dark purple in the
middle because that can really help us
speed ourselves along I made this video
earlier because a lot of people in the
group on Facebook asked about it so I'm
gonna talk about the decisions I made as
I went and I'll probably pause here and
there to you know discuss certain things
so start out you know we'll make some
make some progress on the licorice links
there and what I'm trying to do is set
up these specials like this one alright
the reason why this is a straight down
strike candy and it'll it'll open up
these purples alright so once I get the
middle row opened up then I can try to
get one either one of them either both
sides or one of the sides and then I can
make a special you know candy combo
thing with the dark purple candy and
that'll help me actually more than
anything else so you know I made the
yellow here I'll let it sit there until
I get my opportunity to use it so right
now you know I'm thinking of ways that I
can move down on the board and I'm
trying to avoid actually removing this
candy right here and there's much shot
so now you can see I have my dark purple
set up and the reason why I didn't want
to remove that ice on the yellow is
because then I could accidentally get
rid of one of these dark purples and
then I won't be able to make a special
with it anymore so okay we got a good
shot there to set up a
and up and down striped and what that'll
do if I can set it off the this purple
one on the left hand side is that'll let
me open up one more dark purple and then
I can make a vertical like a striped
candy match if I can I'm looking to and
let me pause that right here like I was
about to say if I can I wouldn't mind
open up but alright because I'm I could
make a t-shape which would be like a
wrap candy special with the dark purple
but I just wanna the reason I pause it
because I just want to say you don't
want to waste like a million a lot of
time or like a million moves trying to
set something like this up if the only
thing you can get is one side that's
fine to go either way here I got lucky
enough to be able to set up these
stripes and now be able to match the
green and orange together it'll hit the
purple and I'll get my t-shaped match in
the middle you can see I really didn't
really didn't really focus on too much
else you see the team match like it
cleared out all the licorice links for
me and took off a massive amount of
layers on the ice which is really the
problem of this level and now I can play
it like most other Jam levels but I even
with 27 moves than that that taken care
of I still really want to take my time
and make sure that I'm setting up the
best combos and things like there I set
up my my color bomb now set this up to
hit with the rat instead of the fish
hopefully you noticed that because you
know with the wrap they all drop down to
the bottom and I'll beat up that ice for
me so things are going pretty well you
know will hit the ice and drop things
down and look to make specials
not a whole lot not a lot of tough
decisions right at the moment you know
we want it we want things to cascade
down and you want to make specials we
just want to watch and take time and
think because like I said even though
they're 17 moves left this level is
really really tough in it and it's it's
really upsetting when you get that close
and don't finish which is definitely
possible at this point so keep on moving
down like I said you know that this does
have all of the colors except for the
dark blue so we we have one the dark
purple but those are gone already so you
know it's there is a lot of it's not a
lot of opportunities to make specials
and stuff like that so you really do
want to kind of look at the whole board
like here I see these vertical green and
you know can I make a kind of make you
know like a color bomb there they got
cleared out but you know I'm generally
moving down like you know where I want
and then here I might have to just
um yeah here I was gonna say I might
just have to set off that striped to
clear out the space and now you know
even though like I said I was way ahead
I still only finished with two moves
left over so that's really the trick is
to plan things out in the beginning it's
gonna take a good board if you don't get
it keep going keep trying to set free
those dark purple I beat this level a
few times when you look at my original
video which if you you know seen you
should to see another example of how to
beat it I'm pretty sure on that one I
only had the dark purple and a striped
match inside of the tee like I did this
time the tee is the best but the stripe
will work so hopefully you'll get it
soon hang in there it's definitely
possible I did this pretty fast
yesterday I was surprised because the
first time I played it I had to play a
lot of times but I did it you can do it
too
I hope you'll like this video and
subscribe to our channel let me know
what other commentary videos you want to
see and I'll make them soon make sure
you tell your friends and I'll talk to
you guys soon